you have another grandbaby on the way
congratulations kelly's big and she's
beautiful and i love it
six months
congratulations the first thing you're
gonna buy is a microphone yes a
microphone and a guitar and pad is
screaming
ozzy i just came in from outside and
there's a 25-foot blow-up of you dude
and it made my day how does it feel to
make your comic-con debut it's great
it's great
i like to see people you know yeah
that's me that's been the hardest thing
over the past three years because i've
been
trying to recover from my surgery i'm
getting there and
it's a stroke but i'm back you know you
look good man you look good you the
recovery is going well i think yeah yeah
yeah we're happy to have you here we're
happy to have you here talk about what
we're collaborating with on here what
are you releasing what can the fans
expect uh
it's my involvement with uh
comics i believe
i don't understand him so i mean
tug my phones to go to our school huh
yeah
we're super excited for we know you guys
collaborated on the video too i watched
this video this morning it was amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
what else can fans expect from this
album ozzy talk to me a little bit about
i've never gone into the studio and gone
oh you know what a good one it's time
for a bad record i love the record i
hope the fans do you
[Music]